大学一年生の時、富山からぼく静岡に行ってたんですけども
その静岡から富山の実家に帰るっていう時がね
ゴールデンウィークとか夏休みとかお盆とか
いろんなタイミングがあって
で同じ境遇の人がいる気がしたんですよ
富山に住んでて
大学で静岡に来てるっていう人がいるなと思って
そういう女の子がいたら一緒に静岡から富山まで
新幹線で一緒に帰ったらすごい楽しいな
とか思いながら
一回もそんなことがありませんでした
はじめしゃちょーです(^_−)−☆
10日とちょっとくらい前に
育てるクリスタルをたくさん買って
それをひとまとめにして
巨大なクリスタルを作ろうって言う
動画をとったんですけども！
今日で
おそらくそれが
完成してると
思います
10日だよね？
10日待つんだよね？
ちゃんと10日で完成って書いてあるので
多分10日はたっているでしょう！！
果たして
クリスタルはどうなっているのか！？
もう
あのなんか
失敗しても俺のせいにしないでね！
ちゃんと10日間待ったからね
え？そんな？
100日間待たなきゃいけないとかないよね？
10日だよね？(ﾟoﾟ;;
わかんない怖い怖い怖い
俺わかんないわかんない
本当にわかんない
お願いお願い知らない知らな…
うわー怖い怖い怖い
え大丈夫なのかな？できてるのかな？
こちらです
怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い
あ、でもなんか
周りはそれっぽい現象…
腐ってないよね？
うわ！ね、腐ってんの！？
抹茶の和菓子作りに失敗したみたいになりました
これクリスタルだろ？
腐ってるだけじゃないの？
やでも。クリスタルっぽいのは出てると思います多分
見ていきましょう
はいと言うわけででいきなりなんですけど
見ますね！
これどうやって見ればいいんだろう？
ちょっと触ってみようかひとまず
大丈夫だ！！
今固い感触あったよ！！
え！キタキタキタ
待って
どうやって…どうしよどうしよドドド
あ固い固い固い
固いこれ！
どうやって…水
そうしよう
もう液体的にはかなり緑っぽいすね
なんか真っ黒になると思ってたんですけど
うわ〜
がっつり緑っすね
うわ！
なんか見えて来てる！
なんか見えて来てるよ！！！
見えます？この
クリスタルな感じ
これこれこれこの四角いの四角いの！
これクリスタルっぽいっすよね！？
ちょっともうコップじゃ取れないくらい近くまで来たので
ちょっと作戦変えます
待って！舌が痺れる！！
ウァァァァァァァァァ
これもう、ザラっといっちゃっていいんじゃないかな
そんな崩れないと思うんすねクリスタル
うぉっ！おっおっ
はっははははは
いけるいける
おお〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜
まぁ、うまくいったんじゃないですかね
ちょっと一回中から出してみましょうか
出せればいいんですけど
あああ、いけるいけるいける
あ、キタキタキタ！！
きた！！
後ろがかっこいい！
後ろかっこいい
なんかスッゲェ〜
こうやってみたらすごさがわかりますね
あぁでもちゃんと出来てるな
なんだしこれ笑
こうやってみるとやっぱちゃんと出来てるなって思います
てかすごっ！
こんなにちゃんとクリスタルになるもんなんですね
これ結構すごいな感動するね〜
わっすごいな〜
あ
めちゃくちゃカラフルなクリスタルを作ろうと思ったら
思いの外透明な感じになりました
繋がってはいますけど
巨大なクリスタルっていうより、なんかこうね
土台にくっついたみたいな感じです
え、でもすごいでもふつうにめっちゃ綺麗なんですけど！
なんか思ったよりクリスタルっぽくて感動しました
近いな
はというわけでクリスタルようやく完成したんですけども
10日間長かった〜〜
最終的にもちゃんと完成してよかったです
ほんと固いんですよめっちゃ固いんですよ
ほら
もうコンコン言いますから
あっ！
やべっ